you've probably had a game like this
somebody starts doing some nutty stuff
surprisingly early in the game really
going ham with their pieces of cardboard
and by the time they've achieved a
decisive win a handful of turns later
one or more other players are sitting
dejectedly and grumbling to themselves
that this matchup was unfair power level
differences within a table can be a
tricky thing to navigate you know it's
not fun if a game ends up being an
absolute blowout with some players
feeling like they didn't even get a
chance and and I generally encourage
trying to coordinate power levels to
some degree at your tables but do you
want to know a secret in most cases like
this the relative power levels of the
decks aren't even the main issue decks
with varied power levels can work fine
in the same pod and games can avoid this
blowout issue but this requires a couple
things to be true and the first one of
these is very simple decks should run
interaction I mentioned in my last video
video how a key table Dynamic that keeps
powerful decks in check in a multiplayer
format is the ability for multiple other
players to trade cards one for one with
a player who is ahead and I don't think
I need to say much else to make clear
the problem with a lot of casual EDH
tables they can't do this because they
don't run enough ways to trade cards
like this a lot of decks throw in some
mid single digits number of generic
removal spells Andor counter spells and
then call it good spending the rest of
their deck on their engines and
synergies and whatnot building up their
deck's ability to function against no
opponents then when a pot of these decks
show up to a table before too long a
player will naturally start to get ahead
and their opponents won't have a lot of
recourse for it this amplifies power
differences because if a deck is even a
little better at what it does say
generating an extra half of a card per
turn in value there will be nothing to
prevent that Advantage from piling up at
an interactionist table a compounding
factor for this sort of dynamic is when
decks have high variance I think the
best way to quantify this is to think
about the difference between the deck's
75th percentile situation when it's
playing somewhat better than average and
the deck's 25th percentile situation
when it's playing somewhat worse than
average most well constructed decks will
have some difference between these two
but not a massive one your 25th
percentile situation won't feel great
but you'll still have plays you're
setting up for and goals you're making
progress toward and maybe you're just
playing a bit slower a bit riskier or a
bit less interactive than usual by
contrast a lot of casual EDH decks I've
seen were built putting so much emphasis
on the ideal scenario the big pop off
factor that as much as 25% or 30% or
even 40% of the time they fail to
perform meaningful game actions this
comes down to one thing above all others
putting in too many payoff cards and not
enough build building blocks to get
there I'd categorize payoff Cards into
two types one is amplification cards
cards that convert your tokens into more
tokens your counters into more counters
your damage into more damage and your
draw into more draw some number of these
cards can be decent for a deck
especially cards that can rapidly lead
to a win or which synergize with a type
of card you'll have especially ample
access to however if you run too many of
these and too few things to be Amplified
you're game plan will be fragile a while
back I had a series of games with a
zakara player who would play multiple
counterd doublers and mana doublers and
various other doublers followed by a
single premium Hydra maybe a second one
if they got lucky if that Hydra had
survived a turn cycle they probably
would have smacked down the table in
short order but in all the games this
happened a single removal spell was
played the zakara player had no counter
magic and just like that they and their
pile of synergy permanence were rendered
a total non-threat I don't want to be
too hard on this player since it seemed
like their deck was pretty newly built
at the time and hadn't been tested much
but this is an example of a trap that's
pretty easy to fall into if you're not
careful and are just adding stuff that
looks good without thinking about the
implications of those additions the
other main type of payoff card is what
I'll call conversion cards ones that
give you one type of resource as a
result of having or spending a different
one for example spending Mana to draw
cards when you've gained life drawing
cards based on having a bunch of
creatures of the same type creating
wolves based on how many cards are in
your graveyard and creating Angels when
you play
enchantments as with amplification cards
these aren't inherently bad and are
indeed a perfectly solid type of card in
moderation but running too many of these
resource conversion cards will have
problematic results for deck consistency
if your deck's core building blocks
already require you to be doing well in
some capacity you're limiting your
ability to get your game plan going in
the first place pair this with running
an excessive quantity of amplification
cards as well and you'll find that your
deck will struggle to get into gear
consistently will struggle to play
through interaction and will struggle to
get up off the floor after it's been
shut down sure you'll have the crazy pop
off games from time to time where things
line up just right but the overall
result of a high variance deck like this
is this sort of All or Nothing dynamic
that I find very negative and if the
whole table is playing this sort of deck
differences in deck power levels will
naturally be Amplified wildly when one
player gets the lucky pop off whereas
the others get stuck with dead hands
full of unmet payoff cards and
especially when nobody has interaction
to close this sort of Gap in performance
decks can feel poorly matched and power
imbalanced even when they're the exact
same power
level as a foil to these sorts of decks
I'm going to dig back into my past for a
moment and talk about a couple decks I
built a few years ago from 2019 to 2022
my play group mostly made up of broke
college students at that point played
exclusively with a pool of1 $30 EDH
decks and we agonizingly tuned and
pruned and fully rebuilt these decks
when needed until each of these decks
played to a power we were satisfied with
the end result of this process was a
pool of decks that are not like most
casual EDH decks these decks have been
brought to life in a setting that is
almost competitive in nature where there
is a meta to keep up with an adapt to
where each deck is played dozens of
times over with every single win and
loss tracked and where Decks that don't
make the cut that don't win a lot of
games get scrapped without further
question in this environment decks are
built with a high degree of consistency
and a lot of interaction because these
factors lead decks to win more games in
this sort of faux competitive
environment this fact paired with the
low budget resulted in a format where
resiliency and ability to grind were the
most important factors for a deck the
funny thing is despite these decks being
built on a low budget and designed to
play exclusively against each other most
of these decks still hold up in games
with Decks that are much more powerful
on paper and a big piece of this is
because of their relationship with
interaction take a deir Rogues list I
built it runs six counter spells six
removal spells two modal cards that can
counter or remove and three stacks cards
in addition the proactive cards in the
deck don't rely on it being ahead or
avoiding opposing interaction even
something like bident ofasa generates
acceptable amounts of value with a
single evasive creature of which the
deck is running
25 these factors work together to make a
deck that is very flexible and which can
perform actions like hindering its
opponents chipping in damage and drawing
extra cards even when it's behind not
only this but the high water mark of the
deck is genuinely pretty high with 30
plus damage combat steps massive draw
extra turns and forcing opponents to
discard their hands all options on the
table for the deck and these plays are
important for allowing the deck to get
to the Finish Line once it's ahead a
rapose discard deck from the same pool
is similarly heavy on interaction it's
running 10 cards plus the commander for
removal as well as 25 cards that cause
opponents to discard cards the deck
cards also work well on their own as a
matter of necessity when a deck's game
plan involves forcing the table into a
hellbent state it's not going to play a
bunch of stuff that requires lots of
setup because that's the exact sort of
deck it's looking to disorient and
hinder through discard spells both of
these decks are consistent grindy and
interaction dense leading them to fit in
quite well at a variety of different
tables and always feel like they're
contributing something to the game even
when other decks have significantly
stronger cards when I reflect on games
with these old decks there's something
almost paradoxical at play these highly
optimized decks Decks that are
overwhelmingly Dedicated To Nuts and
Bolts functionality over all else led to
gameplay that was way more fun to me
than a lot of games I've played with
more conventional EDH Decks that have
wacky card choices and perform lots of
big splashy plays playing Decks that are
packed with interaction and also
resilient to setbacks leads to fewer
feel bad I'm doing nothing type moments
and way more moments where it feels like
you're actually playing a multiplayer
game where different players are trying
to navigate their way to a win while
also keeping their opponents in check
and this is certainly not to say that
playing with a pool of hyper optimized
$30 decks is the only way to achieve
this there are plenty of things that
people find fun about EDH that won't be
found in an environment like this and
there's a reason my playgroup doesn't
play exclusively with these decks
anymore however I think it's worthwhile
to consider these sorts of decks as an
example of how EDH can be played we can
think about EDH decks along a spectrum
with the most interaction High variance
decks out there on one end of things and
then decks like these which prioritize
consistency resiliency and
interactiveness above all else on the
opposite end if you're finding your
games too frequently feeling like a roll
of the dice where some person happens
onto an insane opening and then runs
away with the game just know that
Swingin is a malleable feature you can
move along this spectrum of gameplay and
reducing the swing of your games can be
as simple as following the two deck
building tips I've been mentioning in
this video running more interaction and
improving a deck's consistency and
resiliency by removing payoff cards that
are unnecessary or difficult to fulfill
doing these things will generally reduce
the frustrating feeling of playing a
deck that feels like it's doing nothing
and a table with relatively consistent
interactive decks will feel much more
Dynamic and balanced regardless of how
powerful each of those decks actually
are